ماذا لو كان بامكانك السفر الى اي مطار في
العالم خلال اربع ساعات فقط حلم ظل يراود
عشاق السفر منذ قرابه عقدين بعد ايقاف
طائره الكونكورد الشهيره كانت الطائره
الاشرع من الصوت تقطع المسافه بين باريس
ونيويورك في اربع ساعات فقط
انها اغلى نظرا لوجود كميه هائله من
الوقود اللازم للطيران بشكل اسرع من الصوت
مع كونكورد لم تكن هناك رحلات ذاتي كثافه
كافيه من الركاب وباسعار مرتفع لتبرير
طائراتها الخاصه ولهذا السبب بعد عشره
طائره فقط
شركه اوروبيه ناشئه تامل بيع المزيد عندما
يكون لديها طائره اسرع من الصوت
هذه رحله تجريبيه لنموذج اولي من دون طيار
يعمل بالكيروزين لكن ديستينوس تريد ان
تحلق بعيدا فهي تهدف الى بناء اول طائره
تجاريه تفوق سرعتها خمسه اضعاف سرعه الصوت
وتعمل بالهيدروجين بنهايه العام
نحاول الذهاب الى ابعد مدى وهو نقل الناس
بامان مع الهيدروجين ودون انبعاثات من
جميع انحاء العالم في اربع ساعات فقط
وبشكل خارق للصوت
بناء طائره هيدروجينيه تتسع لخمسه وعشرين
راكبا وتحلق على ارتفاع ثلاثه وثلاثين
كيلومترا وتكون قادره على ربط باريس
ونيويورك في ساعه ونصف ورغم ان استخدام
الهيدروجين في الطيران لا يزال في مهده
فان شركه ديستينوس تراهن على هذا الوقود
نظرا لكونه مصدرا نظيفا ومتجددا للطاقه
ويحوي قوه طاقه اعلى من وقود الطائرات
التقليدي
بين ان الشركه الامريكيه المنافسه بوم
سوبر سونيك تنهج اسلوبا مختلفا ويهدف
مشروع طائراتها المسمى الى الطيران للمره
الاولى عام 2027
سيصمم محرك الطائره للعمل بوقود طيران
مستدام بشكل كامل والذي يمكن صنعه من
النفايات الزراعيه وزيت الطهي على سبيل
المثال وبنات بوم سوبر سونيك نموذجا اوليا
يسمى بوم اكس والذي لم يطير بعد واعلنت
الشركه عن شراكات جديده في معرض باريش
للطيران لمساعدتها على بناء جسم الطائره
واجنحتها يقول خبراء ان الحديث عن عوده
وشيكه للطائره الاسرع من الصوت الى السماء
قد يكون مبالغا فيه اذ لا تزال ثمه تحديات
جمه من اجل بدء حمل الركاب والاقلاع بهم
تحديات يتطلب تذليلها تجارب كثيره وطويله